[Musique]
bonsoir à tous bienvenue dans le 7-8
journal de tv 78 nous sommes le mercredi
à 27 février tout de suite les titres de
cette édition la venue cet après-midi de
françois rugy de rugy dans les yvelines
le ministre de la transition écologique
et solidaire s'est rendu à otto y ait
lieu de la rupture du pipeline
d'ile-de-france de total de 900 mètres
cubes se sont déversés 900 mètres cubes
de pétrole dans des champs et cours
d'eau voisins une catastrophe écologique
et économique
un meeting en vue des élections
européennes à rambouillet à celui du
président de l'upm françois asselineau
la tête de liste de lutter pour ces
élections européennes est partisan de la
sortie de la france de l'union
européenne et puis ce livre pose des
théories nouvelles sur l'univers
développé de façon simple et ludique la
matière et la lumière est écrit par
henri vinay recensait tiny montant
souhaité exposer ses théories à des
scientifiques il est notre invité mais
avant de développer ses titres en appel
à témoins lancé par la police nationale
mme aissa à 14 ans est porté disparu
depuis lundi soir à trappes
elle a quitté son domicile pour sortir
les poubelles mais n'est jamais rentrée
la jeune trappistes a les cheveux bruns
longs les yeux marrons elle mesure 1
mètre 50 miles apportait lundi soir un
jean noir un long gilet gris et des
baskets de couleur bleue en cas
d'informations contacter le commissariat
de trappes environ un million de litres
de pétrole déversés dans des champs
agricoles et aussi dans des cours d'eau
conséquences de la rupture du pipeline
d'ile-de-france de total qui s'est
produite en début de semaine au niveau
d'eau tout y est ce mercredi françois de
rugy ministre de la transition
écologique et solidaire s'est rendu sur
place où les opérations de dépollution
se poursuivre une catastrophe écologique
dont on ne connaît pas encore toute
l'ampleur catastrophe également
économique avec deux exploitants touchés
leurs récoltes de l'année sont perdus et
nous reviendrons plus longuement sur
cette venue dans le journal de demain
total qui s'est engagé en tout cas de
son côté au dédommagement des
agriculteurs et à la remise en état des
terres
chez un dossier que suivra de près l'île
de france la région ile-de-france
indique-t-elle dans un communiqué et de
son côté europe écologie les verts
exigent toute la transparence du groupe
pétrolier sur ce qu'il s'est passé
le parti demande l'application stricte
du principe de pollueur payeur
le parti qui se mobilisera des 10 heures
demain jeudi à aboyer sans avoir il
était candidat à la dernière
présidentielle françois asselineau sera
outil aussi la tête de liste du parti de
son parti lui perd aux élections
européennes de mai prochain en attendant
l'ouverture de la campagne officielle il
réalise actuellement un tour de france
loin à des médias nationaux escale hier
soir à rambouillet pour défendre son
idée du fric site patrick jacques de
dixmude et wilfrid richy alors que
l'accord définitif pour entériner le
président peine à arriver c'est bien
l'idée du fric site que françois
asselineau souhaite imposer lors de la
campagne des prochaines européennes
sortir de l'europe de l'euro et de
l'otan une idée qu'il défend depuis
maintenant 12 ans sa formation lui père
à d'ailleurs été lancée au lendemain de
la création du marché commun par le
traité de rome
notre appartenance à l'union européenne
à l'euro et à l'otan d'une part
verrouille entièrement tous les choix
politiques c'est à dire que les
élections sont désormais vidé de
substance
en fait on a un plan de vol comme pour
un avion qui s'applique quel que soit le
commandant de bord qu'ils soient de
droite ou de gauche et les français le
voient et d'ailleurs ils commencent à le
comprendre
ils votent à droite et votent à gauche
avec toujours la même politique cette
politique qui nous oblige qui oblige
maquereau a supprimé les sf qui
l'obligent à démolir des services
publics les privatiser on est en train
de privatiser
f la sncf qui s'attaquent ou à un autre
au droit du travail
aujourd'hui crédité de moins de 1% des
intentions de vote le 26 mai l'upm
dénonce l'attitude des médias nationaux
qui refuserait de lui donnait la parole
alors qu'il compterait 34 mille
adhérents et des adhésions en hausse
quotidiennement reste qu'il faudra aussi
convaincre les électeurs moins d'un sur
deux pourrait se déplacer aux urnes
avant de pouvoir monter à la tribune du
parlement pour faire passer ses idées je
serai au parlement européen et je
prendrai la parole à chaque fois pour
dénoncer les actes anti démocratiques de
la commission européenne pour dénoncer
cette machinerie bureaucratiques qui
compte des sommes tout à fait
considérable et pour montrer aux
français que la seule possibilité c'est
de sortir de l'union européenne une
centaine de personnes étaient présentes
à rambouillet pour ce meeting de
françois asselineau le scrutin est prévu
le 26 mai le grand débat national se
poursuit jusqu'au 15 mars en complément
des cahiers de doléances et également
des réunions locales des stands dits de
proximité sont également proposées hier
mardi et aujourd'hui un point était
installé en gare de versailles chantiers
avec le partenariat de la poste et de la
sncf
une action notamment tourné vers les
jeunes qui peuvent s'exprimer sur papier
libre ou via un questionnaire le stand
était d'ailleurs animé par des étudiants
avec la présence du secrétaire général
de la préfecture des yvelines
interrogé par michael et demi d'euros
nous avons beaucoup de réunions qui se
déroulent dans les évident nous avons
plus de 180 réunions qui sont organisées
entre le 15 janvier et le 15 mars
on se rend compte que toute la
population ne se rend pas forcément dans
ses réunions et a besoin peut aussi de
s'exprimer on le voit à travers
notamment les cahiers citoyens et donc
l'idée c'était d'aller à la rencontre
des gens en installant dans un endroit
comme ici à la gare sncf chantier où il
ya beaucoup de passage pour qu'il puisse
avoir l'occasion aussi de s'exprimer
le sujet de l'univers vous intéresse
vous intrigue peut-être mais difficile
de tout comprendre quand on n'est pas
scientifique ce livre peut vous donner
quelques idées quelques clés la matière
et la lumière c'est publié aux éditions
edilivre écrit par vous en rêvez d'un
sens bon soir bonsoir à vous êtes
habitants de montigny le bretonneux
ingénieur à la retraite et surtout
passionné par la physique dans cet
ouvrage vous présentez des
d es hypothèse nouvelles sur l'univers
le tout de façon ludique est aussi
simple c'est important pour vous de ce
que vous exposez de l'expliquer au grand
public c'était aussi primordial pour
voilà où exactement parce que d'une part
je peux je suis persuadé que les grandes
lois de la physique elles sont à la fois
pas gérées par des équations mais il
faut des explications physique je peux
pas dire si je dis par exemple une
formule g & gallet même prime sur des 2
de la loi de la gravitation
personne ne va me va comprendre il faut
bien dire bon ben voilà c'est parce
qu'il ya les masses qui sont plus
éloignées que c'était et c'est à dire
aujourd'hui ces théories sont pas assez
claires peut-être illogique je ne sais
pas mais en tout cas pas assez expliqué
ça dépend il ya des théories qui sont
bien expliquées mais y aller
les nouvelles théories entre autres par
exemple sur la relativité où on se
contente de donner les équations voilà
vous voyez ça marche comme ça parce
qu'il ya telle équation
et c'est pas suffisant si on veut que la
science progresse il faut donner des
informations physiques de dire ben voilà
c'est ça c'est très important
mais d'ailleurs tout au long de votre
ouvrage vous avez inséré des rappels de
mathématiques et de physique pour pas
perdre le lecteur pour expliquer à
chaque fois les les théories exactement
à ces rappels de physique qui sont pas
destinés aux scientifiques sont décédées
parce que je voulais que je suis j'adore
enseigner j'aime bien enseigner et puis
j'aime bien on me dit que j'ai beaucoup
de patience et et je trouve que ce livre
il serait bien qu'il se puisse être lui
aussi par des noms scientifiques et donc
c'est pour ça que j'ai mis ces rappels
et je pense que avec un minimum non
scientifique peu le contenu comprendre
alors tu vois pas tous peut-être pour ça
au moins au moins 90% leur donnez nous
peut être un exemple d'une théorie vous
développez que vous reprenez peut-être
dans cet ouvrage
quel exemple ou bruines donald fria il
ya deux théories et sans un peu
complémentaire il y en a une c'est sur
la gravitation
c'est tout simplement pour savoir on est
là sur terre mais pour quand on tourne
avec la terre alors il y a
on dit ça on est entraîné par le sol etc
et cetera mais lorsqu'on est à 10000
mètres
comment ça se passe donc il ya une
théorie d'un champ gravitationnel c'est
donc cette théorie est cette théorie
elle nous permet avec la vitesse de la
lumière comme la lumière est influencé
par la gravitation
elle permettrait d'expliquer un grand
paradoxe pourquoi on la voit toujours
constante et ce sont que des nouvelles
théories c'est aussi des nouvelles enfin
des choses que vous reprenez des tories
qui existait déjà que vous reprenez que
vous réexpliquer c'est à dire que
j'étudie certaines théories qui existe
naturellement qu'ils sont qui sont qui
sont là depuis deux cents ans etc
mais même des nouvelles mais je le dis
je le dis franchement j'ai dit
franchement ce qui est ce que à mon avis
on peut prendre et ce qui est paradoxal
paradoxal ce qui est ce qu'on doit pas
contre eux doit pas continuer on peut
pas continuer comme ça pendant une
centaine d'années il faut il faut quand
même s'ouvrir les yeux et puis dire dire
les choses
elles peuvent choquer les scientifiques
à votre avis pour lui et c'est sûr parce
que pour l'instant il ya beaucoup pour
beaucoup de scientifiques se s'est
toujours passé comme ça dans l'histoire
de la science que ce sera un moment
donné quand on sait que la terre était
plate ou ceux qui disaient qu'elle était
ronde on les montre du doigt etc
après il ya eu newton et puis après
quand il ya eu jean hine c'était pareil
newton était donc la science est en
continuelle évolution c'est son rôle il
faut avoir des doutes et tout ça est
malheureusement il ya beaucoup de
scientifiques se sont cloisonnés
derrière ccc théorie et qui ne veulent
pas qu'ils ont du mal à en démordre
s'ouvrir je le regrette parce que
j'aimerais bien pouvoir dialoguer oui
c'est finalement faut la remettre en
en question cette science
perpétuellement avec le monde aussi
qu'ils avancent c'est aussi il faut pas
qu elle s'enferme vous le dites dans ses
carcans exactement exactement il faut il
faut si on veut que ça évolue il faut
pas oublier qu'on a quand même quelque
chose qui nous pend au nez c'est que
dans 2 milliards d'années il y aura les
des grandes catastrophes le soleil qui
va disparaître andromède etc
il faut qu'on puisse naviguer dans la
litière de la galaxie pour ça il faut
qu'on progresse et puis c'est pas rien
quand il faut qu'on progresse dans la
connaissance et votre but maintenant du
coup c'est de pouvoir échanger avec les
scientifiques de pouvoir vérifier si
finalement vos théories sont valables
exactement c'est vraiment le but parce
que peut-être que ce que je raconte sais
c'est nul c'est possible pourquoi pas
moi j'y crois naturellement honey honey
déjà 3 il croire un mot c'est déjà pas
mal mais ce que je voudrais c'est
christian mais en discuter
tranquillement avec dix scientifiques
qu'on me démonter qu'on voit ensemble et
je me fâche re absolument pas si on me
dit au contraire les met à l'aise alors
ils vont avoir cet échange finalité
pouvoir cet échange est plié une
expérience qui serait simple sur la
gravitation que je voudrais promouvoir
et et être aidés mais même mathématiques
la honte parce que j'ai pas un niveau
mathématique suffisamment fort un donc
aidé par des scientifiques qui aurait ce
niveau là qui pourrait m'aider donc
l'appel est lancé merci henri viii
d'hersant je rappelle que vous êtes
l'auteur de la matière et la lumière
c'est aux éditions edilivre disponible
au prix de 15 euros
le notamment à la librairie le pavé du
canal à montigny le bretonneux aller
pour terminer ce journal petit tour à
présent dans nos salles de cinéma du
territoire une idée de sortie
pourquoi pas en ces vacances d'hiver si
vous n'êtes pas branché balade en plein
air la programmation a des yeux d'elsa
de saint cyr l'école c'est au micro de
patrick jacques de dixmude
[Musique]
retrouvez cette semaine au cinéma les
yeux d'elsa une programmation jeune
public qui s'inscrit dans un festival
dont on est partenaire cette année
encore qui est télérama enfants nous
organisons deux événements ce week end
samedi 2 et dimanche 3 mars
nous commencerons par une journée japp
animations à 14 heures marie est la
fleur de la sorcière suivi à 16 heures
du dernier mme amouroux aux sodas mirail
ma petite soeur et enfin pour la
première fois et sur les écrans en
france l'un des premiers films de jeux
hayao miyazaki le château de cagliostro
ensuite dimanche 3 mars nous vous
proposerons une avant-première à 16h30
d'un très très joli film d'animation qui
s'appelle tito et les oiseaux réalisé
par gustavo steinberg
c'est un film d'animation brésilien
alors qui reprend une partie de la crise
politique que vit le résident
actuellement
alors ce n'est pas du tout un film à la
remise ou larmoyant mais il est quand
même question pour un groupe d'enfants
intrépides de sauver le monde et de
vaincre la peur qui finalement ont
gangrené
le brésil est le monde je suis immunisé
contre la peur ce jour là j'ai décidé
que plus jamais je n'aurais peur et que
je prouverai que mon père avait raison
pour les zozos
bon
[Musique]
mais voilà c'est la fin de ce journal
demain jeudi vous retrouverez wilfried
richy à la présentation d'une nouvelle
édition belle soirée avec tv 78
oh
[Musique]